eine historikerkommission das ist nicht
nur auf und dessen historisch weil die
flieger relativ alt sind zum teil
sondern auch weil es so einen verbund
quasi liegen dass die hängen lässt was
einzigartiges vor allem in österreich
haben wir jetzt alle militärjets in der
luft die in österreich jemals geflogen
sind und wir fliegen im verband mit sehr
unterschiedlichen flugzeugtypen sehr
große herausforderung und ich hoffe wir
können das alles lässt so ungefähr von
einem monat habe begonnen und mir
gedanken zu machen wie das angeschlossen
ist diese formation zu führen
das war dann sehr intensiv eigentlich
ist im monat melden immer wieder
natürlich im gespräch mit dem piloten am
telefon oder per e mail sind das dinge
aufgetreten
die ihr natürlich als 105 minuten weiß
dass hass attacken genug sagt man mit
seinem flugzeug ist und es möglich und
besondere nicht dann muss ich wieder
umplanen es aber nur mit ab in absprache
mit den anderen piloten von den
langsamen fliegen jetzt
es war sehr intensive vorbereitung und
im engen kontakt mit den jeweiligen
piloten
macht mit 3 1 vorne
manager zwei absolut favorite